Angry Birds is the theatrical feature
film based off of the smartphone app
also called Angry Birds and it's about
an angry bird what else they gonna do so
there's an island of happy carefree
flightless birds and one of them is
named red he's voiced by Jason Sudeikis
and he's the only bird on this island
that's very cynical
he doesn't really enjoy life in fact he
treats everyone like crap and due to a
mishap he's involved with he is charged
to undergo anger-management therapy
during this time period these pigs come
to the island and everyone just loves
them because they're different and no
one's seen them before but red he
doesn't like any of his own kind so
immediately he's obviously skeptical
about this strange new species who might
just have a sinister plan I had no real
anticipation for seeing Angry Birds
there was nothing about the trailer that
made me laugh there was really nothing
about the app that made me think it
should be a movie but we live in a post
lego movie world where a movie that
really has no reason to exist that does
sort of come off like a giant product
placement can actually be really good
I'm not going to come out and say this
movie is terrible because it's not the
animation is actually fantastic the
character designs are extremely good
each little feather feels like it has a
life of its own there's a lot of
purposeful imperfections in the way the
birds move like this one scene where red
is trying to step over this annoying
laughing sign that he beat up and he
can't quite get over and he's just sort
of like wiggling his leg a couple times
and I noticed things like that because
that's good animation and that aspect of
this movie really does deserve praise
the animation is top-notch but I
couldn't shake this feeling as I watched
this movie throughout the entire runtime
that the film is just making it up as it
goes along almost like the script is
just kind of being written while you're
watching the current scene they're
already writing the next scene and
hopefully something interesting will
happen then it felt like exactly what it
is someone trying to make a movie about
a smartphone app and running out of
material because it's a game where birds
get launched into towers with slingshots
so I like the idea of Jason Sudeikis as
this angry cynical bird that thinks life
is terrible and he's surrounded by birds
who are so happy go
lucky but the film just doesn't really
get that much out of it the jokes really
aren't that funny and there are times
where you're like I understand why he's
angry there's a scene where this bird is
just sneezing directly into his popcorn
I'm like yeah I'd be pissed if that was
happening to me too but then there are
other times where the character just
really gets annoying and his cynicism
actually grew very tiresome quickly one
thing though and this is sort of weird
because like it doesn't bother me
because I'm an adult and I watch r-rated
comedies so gross-out humor or rude
humor doesn't bother me but if I was
taking my child to this movie I would
actually be surprised by the content
there's a lot of sex jokes
there's jokes where they replace the
f-word with the word pluck and they do
things like that quite often and I was
actually pretty surprised how dirty this
movie was which I guess some people
might be a plus I like family films that
have adult humor that's clever
that requires like brain power to
understand not just haha
the birds talking about having sex all
night I get it for instance like in the
first Toy Story where woody is like the
word I'm searching for I can't say
because there are preschool toys present
that's a smart adult joke in a kid's
film in this movie just have Josh GAD as
this really speedy bird telling all the
ladies to get busy tonight and lay a lot
of eggs like I get it it's a sex joke
and it just kind of bothered me I was
like really if you are like a massive
Angry Birds fan like if you have posters
of Angry Birds on your wall and you play
Angry Birds all day you might enjoy this
film if you're a young kid you might
enjoy it but I really don't see the
purpose of this movie a lot of the jokes
missed the plot isn't very interesting
the characters aren't either
in fact the funniest character in this
movie is Terrence voiced by Sean Penn
surprisingly who spends the majority of
the movie going
I'm going to give Angry Birds a c-minus
the animation is good I'll give it that
the animation is top-notch but I would
highly suggest seeing the nice guys this
weekend guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
Oh